Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
soy lluis Muñoz por Santiago aristia en
esta emisión nos vamos hasta el Salvador
para hablar con Óscar Martínez jefe de
redacción del periódico digital del
faro.net es ganador de premios como el
hillman y autor de distintos libros
precisamente acaba de publicar en la
editorial anagrama los muertos y el
periodista un libro que parte de tres
hermanos asesinados tres hermanos que
fueron sus fuentes historia quilbana con
sus experiencias durante 13 años
plasmadas en libretas moleskine
cubriendo la esquina más violenta del
planeta Centroamérica Óscar Martínez
Bienvenido a la entrevista de France 24
Luis Muchísimas gracias por el espacio
un gusto estar aquí en el libro del en
el comienzo del libro avisos al lector
de la desesperanza que se va a encontrar
en tu texto y le dices lea o abandone
ese es un abandono al que se han
entregado muchos Centroamericanos ante
todas las historias de violencia que
rodean sus vidas
Sí mira el libro básicamente va sobre
eso el libro va sobre los fondos que yo
he conocido en esta sociedad están
desiguales tan violentas tan impunes y
que cubierto durante 13 años y para
contar el fondo me pregunté Cuál era la
historia que tenía digamos un punto de
llegada menos
es menos resuelto y fue la historia de
estos tres hermanos son tres hermanos
que viven en un lugar paradójicamente
llamado la paz en el departamento de la
paz en El Salvador uno de ellos fue
miembro de una de las pandillas
salvadoreñas y los tres terminan
brutalmente asesinados este la columna
vertebral pero nirvanan mucha historia
más de la cobertura de la violencia en
un lugar como Centroamérica te repito
con datos tan graves como mi país El
Salvador que en 2015 tuvo 103 homicidios
por cada 100.000 habitantes que
actualmente en un país de 6.5 millones
de habitantes tenemos a 64 mil miembros
activos de pandillas
en los muertos y el periodista explicas
Cómo sala negra nació como una unidad de
investigación del periódico digital el
faro para responder por qué
Centroamérica es el rincón más violento
del mundo
te sirvió a escribir el libro para
encontrar una respuesta a la violencia
centroamericana
Mira me sirvió definitivamente mucho yo
creo que le sirvió al faro y a nuestro
lector es haber creado el equipo el
equipo de investigación sala negra
fuimos un grupo de personas no solo yo
un grupo de periodistas
documentalistas fotógrafos que cubrimos
durante 13 años para tratar de
explicarnos Por qué nos matamos tanto en
Guatemala porque nos matamos tanto en El
Salvador en Honduras por qué operan con
tanta impunidad los cárteles en el caso
de la migración en México y yo te puedo
decir dos cosas es una respuesta difícil
de resumir de una forma tan rápida pero
si hay dos características que yo creo
haber entendido en primer lugar tres
características una sociedad tan
violenta Como por ejemplo La Salvadoreña
no se construye solo con la intervención
de un país como este Estados Unidos tuvo
un rol fundamental durante la Guerra
Civil que duró de 1980 a 1992
financiando a un ejército asesino que
entre otros asesinó a monseñor Romero el
único santo de la Iglesia Católica
reconocido de este país en segundo Este
es un país donde la impunidad es
campante no solo el caso de Romero por
ejemplo no está juzgado década después
de haber concurrido el asesinato sino
que seguimos teniendo una tasa que ronda
el que de cada Diego homicidio solo uno
llega un juicio solo uno tenga
posibilidad de resolverse y en último
lugar y esto es muy complejo de explicar
Pero renunciaré somos una sociedad que
no conoce la paz no hemos conocido la
paz Nacimos en una guerra luego vivimos
una guerra muy violenta nunca hemos
conocido como se vive en un lugar
Pacífico y cómo se toman decisiones en
un lugar de ese tipo
uno de los protagonistas precisamente
del libro es Rudy sobre que el que
escribiste que sabías que iba a morir
desde el momento en el que no lo
conociste también resulta impactante
cuando es incapaz de contarte un
recuerdo feliz de infancia hablas
También de El Abismo que debe ser como
vivir en una abrevadero de cerdos
representa Rudy la verdadera vida de un
Pandillero
Mira yo escogí a ruda y justamente no
porque fuera excepcional si no lo escogí
porque es muy parecido a todos los demás
muchachos que entre los nueve y los 15
años toman una decisión tan terrible
como si involucrarse en las pandillas o
no a esa edad recluta la Mara
Salvatrucha 13 a esa edad recluta el
barrio 18 revolucionarios y el barrio 18
sureños en el caso de Rudy si el toco
fondo en un momento el presencia una
masacre policial y después de eso el
huye porque la policía lo quería
asesinar para no dejar testigos entonces
Rudy es el ejemplo claro de cómo a sus
14 15 o 16 años él no tiene idea de Qué
edad tiene ni su mamá tampoco lo sabía
de Cómo llegó a tocar fondo y a huir
para y esconderse en el monte una
abrevadero de cerdos la historia de Rudy
es así de terrible Imagínate qué
terrible es que una persona en este caso
yo pueda pronosticar el asesinato de
alguien cuando yo conocí a Rudy el día
que lo conocí la madrugada que por
primera vez hablé con él en el traspatio
de la casa de su madre Yo escri la
libreta hoy Hablé con un muchacho que va
a ser asesinado Rudy fue asesinado de
una manera brutal y además de eso cuando
yo le pregunté en un capítulo de libro
contando un recuerdo feliz le pedí que
me contara un recuerdo feliz de su
infancia Imagínate que Abismo tenemos
que haber sometido un muchacho para que
ni siquiera entendiera Mi pregunta no la
logró responder porque su única
respuesta fue como así respondió a mi
pregunta con otra pregunta y nunca nos
logramos entender
me gustó personalmente mucho la huida
que haces de las etiquetas de buenos y
malos e incluso de víctimas y
victimarios hablas mejor de la pobreza
como condena humillante de hombres de
tristes circunstancias de jodidos
jodiendo a jodidos de sobrevivientes en
los bajos fondos del mundo también te
preguntas Por qué no ganas te hallado y
precisamente Esa es mi pregunta por qué
no han estallado todos esos
Centroamericanos para los que la
violencia forma parte del entorno diario
era yo lamentable lo creo sin duda
alguna la pobreza en una región como
este en Honduras en lugares como San
Pedro Sula o Tegucigalpa que no solo es
un narco estado Honduras sino que ha
estado condenado a los huracanes que le
tocaron durante la pandemia y han
quedado condenados a la miseria con una
clase política profundamente corrupta el
hermano del presidente hondureño está en
un juicio en Nueva York condenado por
narcotráfico y en ese juicio muchos
presentaron al mismo presidente
hondureño como un elemento esencial para
que el tráfico de drogas ocurriera en su
país No pasa nada es una condena
humillante entonces la lógica a mí la
lógica de decir buenos y malos siempre
me ha parecido una lógica precaria por
una razón sencilla explica muy pocas
cosas De qué me sirve a mí etiquetar a
alguien como bueno malo si no es para
una película de acción mala
en cambio explicar cómo construimos a
cierta gente cómo construimos una
sociedad donde tanta gente cree que
matar y morir es parte de la vida
cotidiana Cómo construimos una sociedad
donde tanta gente no sabe leer o donde
cuánta gente acepta desde su burbuja de
comodidad que haya tantas personas
viviendo en un agujero en un agujero
humillante en un agujero indecente en un
agujero indigno bajo reglas violentas
porque la justicia no alcanza para esa
gente Entonces yo creo que esas
preguntas que llevan a mejores
respuestas que llevan a intentar
entender Quién es Rudy te llevan a
intentar entender como lo intenté en mi
libro anterior que se titula el niño de
Hollywood como construimos a un sicario
de la Mara Salvatrucha 13 que cometió el
56 homicidios creo que esas preguntas te
permiten más Porque además te permiten
incluir al sector de la sociedad al que
perteneces si no a vos mismo en parte de
la ecuación que responde a esa pregunta
Entonces el periodismo facilista de
buenos y malos yo simplemente creo que
es un callejón sin salida y un recorrido
y real
si Oscar muchos Centroamericanos también
ante esta situación deciden migrar no en
esta epidemia de violencia y por delante
tienen un camino rodeado de abu
mensuales secuestros extorsiones
arrestos deportaciones muerte es tan
brutal la realidad local como para
enfrentar esas amenazas
Mira yo creo que la gente emigra por
esencialmente una razón Yo Viajé tres
años con los indocumentados tres de esos
años que describo en los muertos y el
periodista lo pasé subido en los trenes
o durmiendo en los albergues con con los
centroamericanos que abandonan mi región
y después regresé yo hice el proceso al
revés primero entendí Cómo huían y luego
regresé a entender de qué huían no es la
manera ideal pero así ocurrió
Mira el camino de México y obvio una de
las crisis humanitarias más terribles
los secuestros masivos perpetrados por
Los Zetas ahora por el cártel Jalisco
Nueva Generación la violaciones
constantes
principalmente a las mujeres pero no
solo en puntos concretos del sur de
México incluso los traficantes de
personas los coyotes repartían
preservativos a las mujeres y le
recomendaban dejarse violar pero
suplicar que el violador usara
preservativo aduciendo que tenían sida
para atemorizarlo un poco así de
normalizada ha sido integrado está esa
regla en la migración centroamericana
fue terrible pero la gente migre
esencialmente por una razón y esa razón
es uno de los mayores motores humanos la
esperanza de que existe una mejor vida
de que aunque tengas que pasar un tramo
terrible de un camino horrible gobernado
por uno crimen organizado despiadado y
por un estado mexicano que es cómplice
ese crimen organizado después de eso hay
una mejor vida para vos Y tus hijos que
levantarte todos los días a las 3 de la
mañana para trabajar en una fábrica o en
un puesto de verduras en el mercado
central vivir bajo la regla de Una
Pandilla que te gobiernan que te
extorsionan que si quiere violar a tu
hija lo va a hacer en la idea de pensar
que hay algo más allá y la idea de
progresar es una de las ideas humanas
más poderosas que ha movido la historia
que esa conllevado al fracaso muchas
veces como el camino de los migrantes Sí
pero es una idea humana que comprendo y
que me parece poderosa y es lo que hace
que tanta gente decida yendo es lo que
hace que tanto hondureños aún ahora
sigan queriendo armar caravanas después
de que ya México y Estados Unidos se
pusieron de acuerdo en porque no le
gustó ver al flujo centroamericano
migrando orondo por sus carreteras
prefieren que esa gente migre oculta por
el monte Aunque sabe lo que les pasa en
el monte y rápidamente se nos acaba el
tiempo quería hacerte Una última
pregunta Y es que en tu trabajo como
periodistas demostrado Los acuerdos
entre el presidente nayib bukeley y las
pandillas algo que el presidente ha
negado mientras mantienen números récord
de aprobación que significa un personaje
como nayib bukele para un país como El
Salvador rápidamente Óscar rápidamente
de ahí bukele es un personaje
autoritario es alguien a quien los
rasgos de la Democracia les estorban
pero es alguien que supo muy bien
aprovechar el momento histórico de
desencanto de los políticos
tradicionales y venderse como el
Caudillo que lo va a solucionar todo en
un país con tan poca cultura democrática
los caudillos como naish bukele tienen
mucho éxito él es muy popular ahora
mismo y sí lo que decís no es algo que
creamos un hecho él ha negociado con las
pandillas para reducir
lo hemos probado con imágenes y
documentos de su propio gobierno
ha sido un placer conversar contigo
Óscar
Luis es un gusto cuando quieras lo
repetimos Muchas gracias y muchas
gracias También a nuestros espectadores
Pueden seguir más contenidos como este
en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]